it's rare that i feel such an
instantaneous warmth with a guest
especially when we're meeting for the
first time hopefully you sense the
comfort and mutual adoration as well as
many viewers often joke it's not a live
stream it's a love stream
norman will be back for a part two so
make sure to write your questions down
in the comments norman wildberger is a
professor of pure mathematics at the
university of new south wales and is the
founder of the youtube channel insights
into mathematics which just passed its
100 000 subscriber mark norman
wildberger is one of the rare examples
of a mathematician examining the
foundations of mathematics in order to
reformulate it ridding it of the
qualities considered abhorrent by the
intuitionists if these phrases or
concepts are unfamiliar to you don't
worry keep watching and it will be
explained in detail within the podcast
today we discuss whether the concept of
infinity is well-founded as well as the
reality or unreality to the real numbers
click on the timestamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channel's themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com
kirchimongo if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliant for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy first man it's an
honor to speak with you i've been
watching some of your videos for
about two years
well thanks so much um you know like i i
think what you're doing is so fabulous
you've got so many interesting guests
and so on so in fact i'm honored to join
the pantheon of uh
of uh impressive people that you've been
talking to uh so it's really great the
pantheon is elevated by your true
monotheism by you being the one true one
well you're very uh
yes uh thank you
i've made quite a few notes and they're
somewhat scrambled so if this interview
is half hazard i will edit it to make it
consistent
and your answers will of course be ella
quint i'm fairly certain of that
so just please just forgive my adhd my
scrambled notes and so on
well likewise i'm likely to um
stumble or uh you know repeat myself or
uh or say the wrong thing and then have
to correct myself because as you get
older and you get more senile these
things happen so
that's one of the nice things about the
youtube format is it's a little bit less
pressure than actually having to write
something formal you know that's going
to be
analyzed you know line by line
i think there's a bit of slack involved
and people
can appreciate that so yes i'm happy
just as a side note man i saw some
earlier pictures of you you were bluff
at one point you look like you put on
quite a significant amount of muscle
yeah i don't know i i i go swimming and
i you know i work out a little bit
sometimes i go bicycling yeah i try to
now that i'm retired i have to um
you know use some time to be more active
uh how about you do you get you get uh
some exercise or you i try to exercise
every day oh that's great it's mainly
because i'm i'm a glut and i like to eat
and gorge myself voraciously and so i
have to offset those calories
kurt has anybody uh interviewed you
a couple times i'm not terribly
comfortable with it because i don't have
much of a well-defined world view a much
more comfortable asking questions and so
when someone asks me a question most of
the time my answer is i don't know i'm
thinking about that and my answer
changes with the seasons my answer
changes yeah
well that's
not necessarily a weakness you know
that's
that can be a good point of view in fact
it's somehow uh representative of a
general scientific orientation a certain
uh willingness to to uh adapt to the to
the facts or to the compelling arguments
um
but yeah just uh just uh
anyway maybe at some future point i
wouldn't mind um you know
asking you some questions and uh
you know about your not not not today or
anything but you know at some
point
about what specifically
well about about your um you know your
trajectory i think it's pretty
interesting you've been a filmmaker and
uh and and and with a mathematics and
physics background and now you're you
know engaged in this very broad
um sort of uh campaign uh
dealing with really big issues
um
that that involves you know huge amounts
of
research into a wide variety of
different
positions you know so that's that's
rather um a unique kind of let's say um
niche that you've got and i think
probably people would be interested in
what's it like
you know to do what you what you do and
how do you do it um it's
torturous that's what it's like well i
like i absolutely love it much like
yourself i'm sure you're like my gosh i
am lucky holy moly i get to do what i
love to do and sure there are tedious
aspects like
maybe formatting a latex document or the
submission process or responding to
certain administrative details
i have that with regard to editing i
hate editing everything else i like to
do i think what we could explore is
first and foremost the unreality of
infinity people would be extremely
interested in that especially because as
you know i interview many people who
are
okay they run the gamut from math profs
and physics profs to people who are
trying to explain what consciousness is
and people who've had insights into
consciousness via certain experiences
and those the latter category tend to
equate consciousness with infinity
whatever that means and they'll say well
the ground of reality is both zero and
infinity you and i will both say i'm
unsure what that means and they'll be
like yes well you haven't reached
enlightenment yet okay well
i still i'm not dismissing them like it
could be the case just because i don't
know what it means doesn't mean it's
false how about we explore what you mean
when you say that infinity is not real
or that you don't like the concept of
infinity why psychologically and perhaps
practically
and then also i'm super interested to
hear about your new ideas for
mathematics and unifying it yeah so well
i think there's there's i have lots of
different interests and so i'm pushing
barrels in different directions um
so uh
there's i wouldn't say that i have you
know a grandiose revision of mathematics
um i i
i have a way of thinking about
mathematics that's more concrete and
explicit than say most practitioners and
i think that there's actually a lot to
be gained by adopting that more more
restrictive and more careful and more
sort of computationally based approach
and i can see how to how to push
mathematics forward in various
directions
with that kind of orientation so we
could explore that i mean you know i
have my algebraic calculus project i
have
a project on rational trigonometry and
hyperbolic geometry that's sort of built
up from that point of view and recently
i've been talking about um
solving polynomial equations on one of
my channels and sort of outlining um you
know a broad new approach to that that
problem
but there's other things as well so you
know um
you know i i guess i i i'm more
comfortable in dealing with specifics
and and and uh illustrating things
through specific examples and maybe i'll
try to do that in our conversation let's
talk about why what your gripe is what
is your gripe with infinity and it's not
just the real number it's not just card
it's all infinities
even the countable infinities yeah so i
would say that um
my my main reservation
probably is in the direction of
uh assuming that what can do an infinite
number of things
so um i think it's worthwhile to point
out you know this classical uh
dichotomy between an ongoing infinity
and a completed infinity
that was already the subject of thought
in aristotle's day
and the ancient greeks had uh had a view
that uh you know an unbounded infinity
was like a like in euclid you know
there's a euclid draws lines but the
hymn lines can be extended that's one of
his sort of axioms or assumptions you
can always extend a line
but it's not an infinite object to begin
with in fact at any particular point
it's always a finite object but it's a
finite object that can be extended
in a similar way you know we can talk
about the natural numbers and we can
count you know from one up to a certain
amount and recognize that we could at
least potentially carry on that counting
but at any given time we are always sort
of only in a possession with only a
range of possible um you know actual
numbers
perhaps constrained by by our computers
our memories or perhaps even more
strongly constrained by the the size of
the universe and
and and perhaps limits that the compute
that the you know the computational
power of the universe imposes on
on on numbers and possibilities for
numbers
so so if we have this distinction then
um i think what what characterizes
modern say 20th century approaches to
infinity is is this idea that we can
capture
the the completed infinity
and that we can
give that a name and we can treat it as
an object ah which which is then a a
prior a prior object that we can then
use for further for further
constructions and such
there's this long standing respect for
the for the you know ongoing aspect
infinity the fact that you know it goes
beyond our view and at some point we
were no longer able to deal with it that
has been lost and we've replaced that
with a a kind of
an arrogance in my view um that that we
can do something which in fact we can't
do
so at the heart of my objection i guess
is is this
implicit belief that
people have that they can
they can do something that they actually
demonstrably cannot do
and you know and whether it be um
working with uh infinite decimals
working with dedicated cuts working with
cochise sequences of
rationals or whatever framework for the
real numbers would be or whether it's
involving infinite sets which are the
basis of manifolds or perhaps varieties
or topological vector spaces right in in
all these cases we're kind of assuming
that we have this this collection of
objects that we actually have it's right
in front of us
and that we can uh we can then use it to
manipulate it in in other ways so
i think what we need to do is uh adopt a
more
modest and and sober
position
and and recognize
what it is that we can and we can't do
we should try to restrict ourselves in
my view to things that that we can do
and a good litmus test for that is can
we get our computer
to
encode to embody these notions that
we're that we're trying to work with
you know so it's not a philosophical
discussion uh particularly where you
know i i create uh you know pleasant
arguments and you create pleasant
arguments you know it's rather
can the computer
support the objects that you're that
you're talking about or that you're
wanting to talk about
i've heard you say before in a few
different interviews
that it's not real unless you can write
it down now i think you're amending that
and what you mean is it's not real
unless you can program a computer to do
it because we can write down real
analysis with infinities so i'm assuming
when you say write it down you have a
specific meaning of write it down well
actually i don't know if we can i mean
what we can do is and what we often do
is we write down symbols for things
you know and and we identify in our mind
like we write down this this uh
this r this r you know this uh
double barred r and say okay there's the
real numbers um but of course that's not
really the real numbers that's just a
symbol for it and in fact we have the
symbols for a whole variety of things
including constants including function
values and such which
actually we have a hard time actually
really writing down in any meaningful
way and and in a completely parallel way
we have a hard time encoding on our
computers
are you of the mind that
underlying reality is something like an
algorithmic process to at its core
nature is computational much like i'm
sure you've heard wolfram talk about
uh
yeah no i don't have that opinion i'm
not saying that's not not a good opinion
and it very well may end up being
jury uh very close to what's what's
happening so i think we have to
certainly uh embrace that as a
possibility you know um but i i feel as
if we're not close enough to the bottom
yet to to really have a good sense of
what's going on um you know i we we
still have to get these submersibles
down further and deeper and and in a
more thorough way before we can really
start
making um i think confident assessments
about what's really going on
but i i do
believe that
the algorithmic or computational
approach to mathematics is a solid one
from a logical point of view
that it gives us
a surety
that
transcends
arguments just with phrases and words
and an english language
it's a kind of a litmus test for whether
we're we're on the right track or not
when a physics student first encounters
infinity as an object well let's forget
about the real numbers it is usually
from an investigation into spinners and
then penrose has
the riemann sphere and says well okay
the top point of the riemann sphere
let's call that infinity and then we
give it some algebraic properties that
we imagine infinity may have so if you
plus infinity with another constant
would equal infinity so i assume you
have an objection to that or maybe you
have an objection far before because
it's a sphere which is a continuous
entity so you're like well i object even
far before that level
um well you know i don't uh object to um
you know the the
the riemann sphere utilizes
stereographic projection to uh you know
you think of the equatorial plane as
being sort of a copy of the complex
numbers and you can then stereograph
uh plea project from the north north
pole so you can sort of wrap the the the
plane or the complex numbers onto the
onto the sphere with the exception of
this north pole and and then as you go
far out on the complex number plane then
you're approaching this north pole so it
makes sense to say okay well we have a
new point here we should give it a name
why don't we call it something so we
could call it aleph or or zeta or
infinity so i have no problem at all
with someone saying well let's use this
particular symbol the laminar scat
symbol and call it infinity
so that's that's not an example of um
of assuming that you can do an infinite
number of things
which is which is
ultimately my my serious objection that
that that you you're believing that you
can do something which you actually
can't in the case of the sphere you can
do this stereographic projection it's
all algebraic you can make it all
algebraic and so it's completely well
defined and i i have no problems with
that so in classical geometry for
example in projective geometry
projective geometry uh uses points at
infinity so-called you know in in a in a
very important and integral way
and in the uh 17th and 18th centuries
these points at infinity had something
of a mystical aspect
and and people didn't really know you
know what what what does it mean to to
have a point at infinity like it's like
the horizon it's infinitely far away etc
but in the 19th century people people
realize that you could you could rethink
this in in terms of uh affine geometry
in one dimension up
so you could understand the projective
plane by
embedding it in a certain way in
three-dimensional affine space
and so and then that
completely demystified the the role of
infinity so the infinity then just
becomes uh those points whose whose
third coordinate is zero as opposed to
the other ones which are have third
chord at one so it becomes completely uh
uh
reasonable and and all the mystery
vanishes
yeah so
so that that's that that's i think a
good thing to keep in mind it it's um
whether the crucial the crucial thing is
are you
assuming that you're able to do an
infinite number of things and and get a
completed result which you're then
then using for further uh constructions
let's drill down into this notion of do
like we can't do the infinity so
specifically what's meant when you say
we cannot do it
well i think maybe it would be good at
this point if if i could sort of
demonstrate some things in a little bit
of a hands-on way because i sort of like
to be explicit and maybe you know that
would be a benefit to your um
to your viewers and listeners can you
see this
yes
i've spoke your name correctly i hope
good good
okay so this is a little program it's
called scientific workplace uh it's it's
quite convenient it's what i use to
write papers with but it's also has some
mathematical computational power so that
i'm quite familiar with so i can use it
to illustrate things great so let me
just start by just uh
showing you a few things first of all
just to impress you with the power of
this um sure
this uh this program okay so here here's
a number okay which i'm just randomly
making and i'm going to ask it to um to
factor this
okay so what you see here is the prime
factorization of this number
okay so that that's good um if i want to
do arithmetic like let's say i want to
do um
eight no i have to go into math mode
okay 8
to the 8
plus
7
to the 7 okay so there's there's some
potential arithmetic if i evaluate that
i get some number like this
if i if i make this 8 into 18 let's say
in this into 17 i can evaluate again i'm
going to get some some bigger number so
we we have the potential of doing
arithmetic here but
one of the things that i think people
perhaps don't appreciate is that
our ability to do arithmetic smoothly
diminishes it diminishes
quite steadily as the numbers get big
and
you know a lot of talk about infinity
and the problems of infinity are a
little bit of a red herring because
actually
the essential
problems actually manifest themselves
long before you get to infinity
they manifest themselves already when
you start dealing with bigger and bigger
numbers
so for example if let's say i i replace
this eight um with an eight to the eight
and this um so now i'm talking about
um
you know this thing here
so if i was do to do this i i'm not sure
if i really want to do this um but okay
let me just try okay so that this is
what's going to happen um my computer is
going to uh sit here for um and i don't
know how long you know
maybe some some years okay
yeah
now it it has realized that this is his
way
okay
okay
so um
okay and edit has told me okay this is
this is silly you're not able to do this
now
so when we when we do a lot of um
calculations in in in mathematics
we're
we're not taking this
crucial aspect of reality of
computational reality uh sufficiently
you know uh seriously
so let's say for example that um
i want to calculate exponential function
of 7. so i want e to the 7. so what what
is that
so i could evaluate it numerically i'm
getting this this number here so what is
actually e to this to the seven well um
you will know of course that this thing
has a power series expansion and i can
just remind people what that is by going
to power
series okay
so here here is the power series
expansion for e to the x and most
functions that physicists deal with in
fact that mathematicians deal with are
all
sort of something similar like this that
they can ultimately be reduced to to
series which which carry on okay they're
they're ongoing and the the arithmetic
with such things is very parallel to
arithmetic with polynomials polynomials
are just sort of the finite versions of
this where you truncate and and do the
arithmetic and then you get a finite
polynomial
so uh what we're really doing when we
calculate e to the seven is we're
supposing that we're going to replace
this x here with with seven and we're
going to calculate all these terms and
we're going to um you know see see what
what we get
but so this is this is a key example of
a calculation that actually we cannot do
in its entirety
so you you cannot
you cannot
uh
look at this this sum
uh going to infinity
um and and calculate the entire thing
what what you can do is you can truncate
it like like what right the program is
doing right here okay so like this is
what what your calculator you will do
your calculator will dispense with all
the terms past some point
and just use this finite polynomial to
calculate e to the seven
but with with this understanding that
there's there's some uh some some
inaccuracy or some some error because
we've truncated things and just as a
note to the audience that term you
erased is a stand-in for an infinite
sequence of additions
that's right that's right yes so this
series ostensibly carries on to infinity
okay
with the coefficients that that are in
front here getting uh increasingly big
in the denominators and then these
powers are getting increasingly large
um and and when we calculate e to the
seven we're thinking about you know
adding up all of these things so we
could we could talk about you know the
difficulty in in in doing this to
infinity but before we get to that
difficulty we we get to the difficulty
of of getting to the range where we're
talking about numbers even of this size
so in other words if i take this sum
okay um for let me write it out as a sum
so if i take the sum from k equals oops
k equals zero
two okay let me uh put in here uh
ten
to the 10
to the 10 okay of and what are we
summing we're summing 1 over
k factorial
and times x to the
k
okay so that's that's not e to the x but
that's
uh
like the first 10 to the 10 terms of e
to the x
okay
so we have not gone to infinity but we
have gone a long long ways
and already at this stage we are talking
about something that doesn't make sense
computationally on our computers
and and more crucially we're talking
about something which does not make
sense in the universe as as we as we are
in
in other words this number here already
even though it's relatively modest by
big number standards is already
ensuring that that this
this computation will overwhelm the
computational aspects of the entire
universe
in fact i took to be completely
confident about that statement if i go
to
one more okay now i can be completely
confident i've got a
10 to the 10 to the 10 to the 10. so
that that's that sum is going to be
completely overwhelming the the
computational
capacity of the universe even if we use
the entire universe and even if we write
at the planck scale
sure
so
so here you see there's this fundamental
problem that we we cannot calculate this
initial sum so in
to be honest we have no right to assert
the
the existence or or say anything really
much about uh
some which is vastly superior vastly
bigger than this one namely going to
infinity so this is very disconcerting
to uh to a modern analyst they don't
want to think this way because
this means that
the the exactness that they currently
ascribe to something like the
exponential function or or the cosine or
the sign or the tan or the arctan or
one of hundreds of other such similar
things
that exactness is is illusory and that
it's uh more a game that we're playing
that's not really computationally
valid so we would we would like the
exponential function to be a function in
the sense that it inputs a real number
and outputs a real number
but the reality is that's not what
happens
i know you mentioned that this is not a
philosophical statement but to me it
sounds philosophical and underneath it
has a practical nature to it that we
practically cannot calculate this and
then it also has the term
existence or real this is not real now
just for those who are listening i know
we use the terms real number we
shouldn't use the word real number
because it muddies the waters so you're
saying that this
is not real because you can't input
and get an output in the universe
so is it a practical claim i'm trying to
understand what the objection is it's a
practical objection or it's an
in-principle objection so it it's really
ultimately a question not of existence
but of definition i mean i know often we
phrase these questions in terms of
existence like does infinity exist or
does e to the seven exist etcetera but a
prior and and usually more uh profound
question is you know what is the
definition of infinity or e to the seven
that's what you want to think about
first
so um
what i'm saying is that the definition
of e to the seven is not it's not a
valid definition let me see if i'm
understanding it correctly so you're
saying it's not valid because inside e
to the any number is an infinite amount
of steps we cannot do an infinite amount
of steps therefore the definition it
fails at the definitional level
that's right that's right we cannot get
to the end of the rainbow so for us to
say let let g be the pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow is is is is not a
proper definition
now what if someone says like a child
says or a first-year student which at
least i was a child when i was like
childlike and naive like what if they
say okay forget about
whether or not e to the 10 to the 10 to
the 10 exists and think of it as well if
we treat this
as if it exists then it allows us some
simplicity in other calculations so for
example i have a circle here
this diffuser right here and i have a
circle if i treat it mathematically like
an actual circle it simplifies
calculations for me whether or not it is
a circle or whether or not a circle
exists
that's another question so what if i use
it almost like an architect uses design
so i use this i know the final building
won't look like this but hey for my
purposes it's fine so what are your
objections to that first of all your
your choice of the circle is a very very
good one because the the circle actually
is at the heart of a lot of these
difficult issues even historically uh
going back to the origins of
trigonometry with the uh the astronomers
uh the greek astronomers and hindu
astronomers and so on
um
the the need for uh for essentially trig
tables that that related uh angles to x
and y-coordinates essentially
i mean these these
the people who created these tables
realized that you could not
create exact values that this was
necessarily an approximate story
and that that approximate aspect has
permitted
almost not all but almost all
trigonometric tables since ancient times
and so there's a distinction i think a
really important distinction here
between things which are intrinsically
approximate and things which are
intrinsically exact
and i suppose one way of
thinking about my objection is that i
want to make very clear the distinction
in our minds between
uh being on the exact side of the fence
and being on the approximate side of the
fence
okay um and i think
yes it that does complicate things in in
the sense that whenever you
uh add distinctions on into a theory it
will typically complicate the theory but
it also makes it more
accurate and representative of reality
in mathematics most
most applied mathematicians first of all
mathematics has been largely applied
mathematics for for most of its history
i think perhaps we should we should say
that
um i mean a lot of the great
mathematicians you know uh were
essentially applied mathematicians they
were interested in concrete problems and
solving solving real life problems and
they they recognize that a lot of the
techniques that they had
were sort of operating in this
approximate space
you know where
like like sine and cosine you don't you
don't know exactly what the sine or
cosine of some particular angle is but
you you know it's two three or four
decimal places because you have tables
and that's good enough to solve whatever
problem that you're working on
this this is i think a really important
distinction and you could characterize
mathematics pure mathematicians desire
for real numbers
okay and and we said we were going to
maybe stick to infinity but but to be to
be honest it's really the real number
question which is really at the heart of
this this discussion okay the the real
critical um issue is
what's
what's the correct arithmetic
of of the continuum
because that's the basis for for for
modern geometry that's the basis for for
analysis
see historically the the role of
infinity has been a supporting role
um
infinity arose with cantor and promoted
by dedicant as a supportive structure to
frame a theory of real numbers
this is sort of how the story goes and
this is essentially why it's so
important for analysts to
to you know play along with with modern
set theory because they they see that as
a buttress for the the theory of real
numbers
but
the
the problem with with real number
arithmetic which i point out uh in a lot
of places is that this this lack of
being able to actually perform
calculations
is is right in your face if you really
uh work with the computer
so i i have to illustrate what i'm
saying here
in in a couple of important examples
okay so let's have a look at this
elementary problem which every primary
school student who has done uh
some some fractions will know so if one
half plus one third plus one fifth if i
evaluate that i get 31 over 30.
and
we can accept that
you know
a primary school student who's learning
fractions ought to be able to make this
calculation
now suppose that i
i want to demonstrate you know real
number arithmetic
which involves
things like x e x plus seven or cosine
of five or or the square root of of
eleven or something like that if i try
to uh well my favorite example which i'm
always
telling people is is this one here so i
should
for consistency write it down what is pi
plus e plus square root of two
okay so my computer is pretty smart and
if i ask it to to calculate this
just to evaluate it you see what it
gives me it gives me the same thing back
again
and this is not just because of this
program if you ask mathematica or pretty
well any other program you know to
calculate to do this arithmetic you're
going to get something similar
but it's not just this it like i could
do this in a
a
myriad of different ways i could take
log 4 plus tan of 7 and i ask my
computer what is that
that's another example of you know of a
calculation or i could ask you know what
is um cosine of
three
um times uh
you know sine of
seven
oh it doesn't know maybe
you have a problem with this because
i'm sure there's a way that you can get
it to do a decimal expansion oh yes i
can do that yes absolutely so i can i
evaluate these things numerically uh
very easily so i can evaluate this
numerically i can evaluate all of these
numerically
and it's the numerical evaluation that
an applied mathematician is going to use
so
the
the applied mathematician only needs to
work to four or five decimal places
maybe if you're a theoretical physics
student maybe to 10 decimal places in
some strange
situations but typically to just a few
decimal places so
that's that's not a problem but
from a pure mathematics point of view
this idea that we have a valid
arithmetic of real numbers
is
it would seem contradicted here right
here i i'm i'm taking
very simple real numbers and i'm
performing very simple arithmetical
operations on them
and i'm not getting
any kind of of calculations
the reality is my computer and almost
all
all computer programs that i know of are
incapable of doing real number
arithmetic
and you can frame that you know we have
various framings of real number
arithmetic in pure mathematics we talk
about dedicated cuts and we talk about
equivalence classes of koshi sequences
there's continued fractions there's
other ways it doesn't matter how you
frame it
their computational reality is always
the same that you can't actually compute
exactly
these operations on on on
relatively simple real numbers
what do people who are analysts
say to you in their response or their
objections
so
an analyst is going to be very
uncomfortable with this conversation
you see um before before jedican came
along with uh his theory of dedication
cuts
people knew about these problems uh a
lot because for centuries earlier people
had been making computations
with uh maybe i'll stop
sharing the screen it's getting boring
what is it exactly that the analyst may
put to you as a rebuttal
yeah so most analysts are going to be
uncomfortable with this this train of
thought
because
historically long before dedicant the
cop theory came about in about the 1870s
the the working the working prototype of
a real number was an infinite decimal a
so-called infinite decimal
and
it's not too hard to to see that if you
want to have a theory of arithmetic with
infinite decimals
that's going to be problematic because
because the infinite nature of of the
decimals means that it's going to be
difficult or actually impossible to
prescribe
what the operations are
so for to be
so to be specific suppose that you're
given two computer programs that will
output the nth digit of two
decimals
and you're asked to write another
computer program that will output the
nth digit of the sum of those two real
numbers
you just said the nth digit of two
decimals you mean the nth digit of the
sum of two numbers or
yeah so let's say you you want to sort
of incorporate real number addition
on a computer in in a computational
fashion the inputs are two infinite
decimals given as programs
and digits
and your output is supposed to be
another program of the same kind which
represents the sum of those two things
so if you think about this for a little
while the way
kids are taught um
decimal number arithmetic in schools you
have two decimals to add them you start
on the right hand side
and you start on the right hand side and
and then the carries go to to the to the
left and so then you pick up the carries
as you proceed from right to left
the problem is with if you have a two
infinite decimals if you have in some
sense there's no right point to start
with right so what you have to do is you
have to typically sort of truncate and
then do some partial calculation
then go further trunk it again do uh the
calculation again and then modify what
you've got um
every time you go
but the problem with that is there's the
problem of carry of nines so at some
point you have you have the the
potential of getting a lot of nines so
that you're never in in possession of a
program that will guarantee that you've
got the nth decimal place
because
that nth decimal place could conceivably
depend on stuff that's happening very
very
far down down the track and you don't
know how far that's the critical thing
okay
so
at some level uh analysts would have
been aware that that
in terms of a theoretical number system
the infinite decimals don't really work
this is why this is why you the the 17th
century people 18th century people
didn't
create such a theory they would work
with decimals all the time
but they didn't have a theoretical
understanding of those and then they
kind of avoided it because they knew of
these difficulties
so so the dedicant cut story the koshi
sequence uh equivalence class story
these are attempts by pure
mathematicians to kind of circumvent
um these difficulties would not face
them squarely on and surmount them but
to actually sort of circumvent them and
and and and and
you know and make it look like like we
have an arithmetic of real numbers when
we actually we don't
we don't have a valid arithmetic of real
numbers that's just the way the world is
[Music]
and it's not because we're not smart
enough it's it's because we're
attempting something that's
intrinsically impossible what we end up
having to do is we have to then uh
separate our mathematics from from
computational reality we have to kind of
go up you know
and and go up on stilts so that we never
touch the floor you know we're walking
around on these stilts and and not
looking down just always looking up
um so
this means a a lack of contact with with
mathematical reality ultimately
and that manifests itself across i mean
i could talk for hours about these
manifolds varieties topological vector
spaces lead groups you know um
there's there's so many areas of
mathematics that um
get
get disrupted by the the weakness of our
underlying numerical system that's the
so-called real numbers or the associated
complex numbers i think it'd be a great
time to give an example of a problem
that arises when one
doesn't take this computational view for
example in physics we use e
all the time it's rare to find a formula
without e so what is the solution we
just replace this with something else is
is physics breaking down in some way now
i know with feynman path integrals you
can solve it by saying it's finite oh no
it's see i i i think you you've
yeah you i think you physicists are are
fine because you're not thinking of this
e as an infinite decimal you're thinking
of e as um
as a finite decimal of some variable uh
number of decimals which you can kind of
choose you can choose the amount of of a
resolution depending on the problem that
you have in mind
so you're playing along with with the
pure mathematician's notation because
you've gone to math class you've learned
about e and so on but effectively you're
adopting an applied mathematical point
of view which doesn't require the
infinite decimals
you know and and you're actually working
in a numerical system
which is a an approximate decimal system
which is not the real number system it's
it's what the computers actually do you
know you have
some finite number of decimals and you
have to work with that and you have to
deal with truncations and round off and
and so on so forth right right right
now there's this physicist i'm not sure
if you've heard of him his name is
nicholas jisson
have you heard of nicholas justin i have
his argument against the reality of the
real numbers goes as follows i think
it's an argument more about discrete
space-time though i don't know if that's
exactly the case if an electron carries
with its space-time point it would have
to carry an infinite amount of data to
specify a certain real number and thus
it would create a black hole now i don't
know if i buy that argument per se
because it means that the electron
carries with it at space-time point i'm
not sure what that means but for people
who feel like what you're saying is
radical in many ways some physicists
already are in line with this thinking i
think you're absolutely right and
you know the 20th century physics has
has um squarely acknowledge the the
the fact that our our our underlying
space time is not infinitely divisible
you see the the cont the model of the
continuum is the real number uh the real
number line it really assumes an
essential infinite divisibility of of of
the line right that's the point and
you've got as many decimals as you want
so every time
you add a decimal you're dividing by ten
okay but physicists know that that's not
the way the world is you you get down to
10 to the minus 30 or whatever and you
add a planck scale and then and then
that divisibility just erodes
i have a physics question for you so in
quantum mechanics if you have the most
let's take the most basic wave function
and let's say that the wave function is
real some people say the wave function
is real whatever that means well people
who believe in the multiverse eight is
the most real there's only the wave
function
okay now let's say we have a simple
system where it's half half so half up
half down
okay then the wave function itself has 1
over square root of 2 because you have
to square the wave function to get half
are you saying that that's 1 over the
square root of 2
is not the wave function cannot be that
because the square root of two does not
exist
no no that's um that's that's just to
obtain a kind of a uniticity um
unitarity um
you know like um
how should i say um
you you you can easily have equal you
know extent in this direction equal
extent in this direction like you can
have the point one one okay so the point
one one in the plane okay it's it's
distance from the origin is is is uh
square root of two but in rational
trigonometry which is you know my
preferred way of thinking about
metrical geometry it's not the distance
that matters it's the quadrants it's the
square of the distance it's the sum of
the squares okay so
if you adopt a rational trigonometry
point of view those kind of objections
having to do with distance
more or less disappear
so this is like
preferring preferring einstein's
interval to to the square root of the
interval you know to not insisting that
that we we take square roots of our
metrical quantities just to stick with
the metrical quantities themselves than
the natural quadratic ones let's say
you're speaking to a quantum physicist
who constantly has to take the square
root in a sense because the square is
what the wavefunction's probability is
the probability distribution is the
square
so you're saying that that is the
fundamental quantity not the
wavefunction itself
sorry that is the real quantity the
probability distribution is the real
quantity forget it no no i i wouldn't
say that i would have to be uh better
versed in in physics and and have an
opinion on on the nature of quantum
mechanics um
to to be able to you know to say that
um i think it's very interesting but i
don't have a strong opinion as to the
the true role of of the wave function
and how it should be interpreted
okay so let's talk about
not precisely about rational geometry i
believe that's what it's called rational
geometry rational trigonometry is what i
call it yeah
so let's talk about rational
trigonometry
not it itself but actually what led you
to that so you have this knack it's a
strange knack of saying strange in a
positive sense to look at what is so
elementary what's been looked at a
thousand times to the point now becomes
overlooked
and say well what is really going on
here that's a phrase that you've used
what is really going on here in fact you
say that that's a great
phrase to keep as a mantra as a phd
student to understand your phd what is
really going on here now
see for me if i was to look at something
as quote unquote simple as the circle i
would get so bored and i would move
on however
you don't have that you you're wondering
what the heck is going on here so please
describe to me psychologically where
does that come from and then what
insights have you gleaned
from investigating what ordinarily is
seen as
overtrodden ground
ground without any new territory to
explore
okay so let me answer that um in a sort
of a retrospective way i mean the actual
way that i stumbled upon rational
trigonometry was it was somehow a
sequence of accidents and maybe that's
not so interesting but in retrospect i
could say that
um one can be motivated by the desire
for for um generalization and generality
and and sort of universal
applicability
so
after after um descartes
cartesian revolution in geometry we've
we've we've adopted this uh very
um cartesian point of view where where
numbers and and everything it depends on
on on a prior number system
and
so the
the usual uh
assumption is that okay it's the real
number system or perhaps from my point
of view the rational number system but
if you're a modern physicist you you
probably want to entertain possibility
of other number systems like like maybe
even finite finite number systems right
maybe the universe is some some finite
automata with some vast number of but
finite pieces in which case it might be
that a finite field is actually a more
appropriate
uh sort of underlying number um
system in which to model things so so
what can
uh aspire what we can aspire to then is
is to try to create a geometry which is
so flexible that it will work in
in different systems that it doesn't
depend on having a particular underlying
number system
and more generally that it works in such
a way that it doesn't depend on a
particular quadratic form
so you know the the properties of the
euclidean quadratic form where the unit
circle is is a circle versus say a
relativistic quadratic form like in like
th
in in einstein's special theory where
you know a unit circle has a has a
hyperbolic aspect
that difference should not perhaps be so
important we should aspire to having a
theory of trigonometry that works just
in in the relativistic setting just as
well as as in the euclidean setting
now i think it's fair to say that
physicists have struggled with with this
because um the the current trigonometry
is not well suited for for relativistic
applications
um but one of the advantages in rational
trigonometry is that you know you you
kind of zoom out and and you see what's
going on in a bigger way and so you see
that these are all just aspects of the
same kind of thing and you can basically
deal with them um sort of all at the
same time if you set things up correctly
so you can work over a general field and
you can work with a general quadratic
form and you can do that right from the
beginning if if you set things up this
way and then and then you cover all
these things you know at one blow so
it's just hugely more powerful
even though you know particular aspects
of of of something or other
that
you know that that we might be used to
in the cleaning world might not appear
because because they're they're not
general enough
you know
so so that's that's that's a big
advantage i would say that's like a
a key selling point to the rational
trigonometry point of view
a somewhat more subtle
advantage is that it also makes it
easier to unite the affine and the
projective stories
so in geometry there's largely sort of
two
frames of thought there's sort of an
affine or vector space or linear algebra
sort of point of view and then there's a
projective point of view
and um
and with with rational trigonometry
orientation you can you can adapt the
affine story to the projective story
much much more easily
and then what's what's called hyperbolic
geometry emerges as a natural
consequence of of
of the projective side of things
and that turns out to actually to be uh
quite closely connected with the
einstein minkowski kind of geometry so
that's
that's good also
what i was getting at firstly actually
what is the status of rational
trigonometry is it a field that that's
flourishing is it primarily you working
on it are you having a difficult time
convincing your colleagues
oh you look uh it's primarily me and and
my students um
it it will i i i'm sure it will uh take
some time for for people to slowly you
know come around um
partly also because i have other
projects that i'm involved with i'm
involved with this algebraic calculus
and these various other things so i'm
not
sort of solely concentrating on
promoting um rational trigonometry and
going around giving talks about how
great it is um i've got other things to
do so
um
yeah i mean eventually people will will
realize that it it's very powerful but
it will take some time
for the people who are watching the
series on norman wildberger's rational
trigonometry the links are all in the
descriptions the links to virtually
every one of whatever we've referenced
are in the description and you can watch
that and you can be a champion of it and
contribute to the field it's a new field
it's a burgeoning one okay now for my
second question
what i was getting at before was
psychologically what is it that makes
you go into looking at
babylonian texts and what archimedes
thought i don't know of any
mathematician or any physicist that goes
back that far in fact it's rare to find
even a physicist outside of a tenured
professor who's even looked at newton's
original works you're never assigned a
page of newton you're never assigned a
page of likeness so what is it that as
physicists and mathematicians we just
assume okay well
it's it's all been filtered and we're
we're taught to the best of it so we
don't need to go back to the sources
what's making you go back to the sources
well first of all i i'd say i'm not
alone at all in this i think
maybe
as a mathematician mathematicians are
aware of a very broad history
mathematics has been around for a long
time
astronomy in its in its early days was
really sort of part of mathematics
the terms are almost synonymous so we
think of ourselves as having a you know
a 3000 year history
you know
and if you include the babylonians it's
more like four four thousand years
and so there's actually quite a lot of
mathematicians who are quite interested
in in aspects of the history of
mathematics so i don't think i'm unique
at all in that regard uh but with
respect to babylonian mathematics i'm
especially interested in in that well
first of all because my initial interest
was with plympton322 and then the
realization that with daniel mansfield
that this was really essentially a
trigonometric table but sort of along
the lines something similar or akin to
to rational trigonometry in you know in
1800 bc
but
another really good reason to think
about the babylonians is because
they had this absolutely remarkable
numerical system i've been talking a lot
about numerical systems right so
we actually have a lot of numerical
systems floating around
currently you know we have we have
integers we have rational numbers we
have we have approximate decimal numbers
we have real numbers et cetera
and for a computer programmer you know
and then there's also binary uh you know
kind of system uh these these uh
different types of number systems are
all probably uh best kept apart and then
separate and and and then you have to
build bridges between them so it's
really interesting to to find out that
the babylonians uh 4 000 years ago had
this other number system this base 60 or
sexism system which was in in in many
ways more powerful than than our systems
this is a a sort of a mind-blowing uh
fact you know that even today if if you
if you had to to start from scratch and
said okay we're going to do math from
scratch let's decide which number system
we're going to use should we use base 10
should we use base 2
there would be a good argument to be
made to use the babylonian base 60.
there would be a very good argument to
be made i'm not saying that that would
necessarily prevail but it would be a
very interesting discussion to have
and so it's completely fascinating to me
that these people you know
so long ago living under what we would
consider very primitive conditions had
such an evolved
mathematical numerical system
it's
it's completely remarkable to me so i
think that's so intrinsically
interesting
besides the many other things that they
did i mean that's just one one aspect of
their remarkable culture
can you give an example of the
sexagesimal system being better than the
base 10. some non-interesting there's a
there's a really good example to keep in
mind
when you're learning fractions in school
you know and and actually the
relationship between fractions and
decimals
you learn that most fractions have
uh repeating decimals
that is they are not finite decimals but
some fractions uh have finite decimals
like one quarter that's 0.25 you know or
1 8. and in fact the the fractions with
finite decimals are the the ones with
denominators whose whose um whose
factors are all twos and fives
oh i didn't know that yeah so two a if
you have a denominator and it's a
product of some power of two and some
power five then that's going to be what
we might say a regular number in our
system is gonna have a finite decimal
now the the babylonians basically did
like a decimal arithmetic they didn't
deal with fractions they did with deal
with decimals but they were finite
decimals they had no infinite decimals
but
in base 60 since 60 has
factors 2
3 and 5 there's crucially the the factor
three that gets added to the list for
regular numbers in in base 60.
so if you're a babylonian any number
that is made out of just twos threes and
fives if that's in the denominator of
your fraction then you're going to be
able to convert it to a a finite decimal
that means something like six
one over six one over twelve one over
eighteen one over twenty four you the
the number of numbers which are regular
in your system is hugely
more and so you get a much more
tractable
arithmetic
so if you if you have to restrict
yourself to finite decimals that's very
restrictive for us because we can't
capture a lot of fractions that way
the babylonians could capture a lot of
fractions that way
so their their sexagesimal sort of
decimal arithmetic was
demonstrably more powerful than ours for
exactly that reason
and this this this uh they had tables
for everything so they had actually
tables of the reciprocals of like you
know one over six what what's that as as
a as a sex adjustment decimal so they
they had they had lists of all their
regular numbers and they had and these
are things that
all the scribes would have would have
memorized
so this this is a very concrete example
of a powerful
advantage to the base 60 system
is there a non-arithmetic example
like let's say we go all the way to
complex is complex analysis affected by
this
uh is complex analysis affected by this
that's a good question um
i i might have to think about that but
but generally speaking a lot of like
once you once you adopt a sensitivity to
to
removing real numbers okay
then then um
questions like you know things like the
square root of 2 or the cubed root of 7
or something have to be constructed
algebraically if you want an exact
theory if you're an applied
mathematician you can still use square
root of two equals one point four one
four you know no problem but if you want
to sort of an exact algebraic system you
have to start constructing uh what we
call extension fields
to to um
for these these um radicals to to to
live in
um and and so a lot of problems in in
geometry and also in in other areas um
sort of meet meet this issue of whether
a given number is a square or not this
is like a critical question you say like
can you take the square root of seven
what does that mean it means is there a
number in your number system whose
square is seven
so that's that's a number theoretical um
issue
now that's not going to change if you
change your change your base okay
okay but it will change if you change
your number system but
so
whether there's something like that uh
with a babylonian system in which in
which the the 60 uh manifests itself in
terms of some some number theoretical
property i'm not sure but but my guess
would be yes because actually there's a
lot of number theoretical questions that
are somehow based
base 10 or oriented but
maybe they're not that interesting
this occurs to me right now this may be
a foolish question given that real
analysis needs to be revamped in your
eyes at least yes then see to me this
word beauty is misused in
in phys not maybe it's an aesthetic word
it's a subjective word so for me to say
it's misused
who am i to say some people say string
theory is beautiful i think the word
natural is more appropriate when it
comes to string theory however beauty
i reserve for complex analysis there's
something about complex analysis that to
me is absolutely beautiful though
unnatural which is strange but we can
talk about that after let's assume that
you share that you know what i'm talking
about when you say compared to real
analysis complex analysis is beautiful
and simple now
does any of that beauty or simplicity
get removed when we make this change
from the real numbers to this more
finite computational approach does
anything i don't think it does i really
don't think it does but
that's a little bit of an optimistic
statement because it it does involve
people having to go over things and and
and go over all the traditional theories
and say well how are we going to
redo this how are we going to state
these things how are we going to capture
these ideas
without uh assuming that we can do an
infinite number of things
but i i do believe that that the
intrinsic beauty of complex numbers will
complex number analysis will shine
through in any case
maybe it becomes more beautiful who
knows it becomes yes i believe it'll
become more beautiful because the the
essential aspect of it will will become
clearer
see complex analysis in complex analysis
um so-called analytic functions play a
bigger role than they do in real
analysis
so an analytic function is is like the
one i showed you i've been showing you
on my site workplace things that have
power series roughly okay and in complex
analysis you have a lot of reasons to to
restrict yourself to analytic functions
they have all these remarkable
properties in real analysis uh less so
and so in real analysis there's often
people use bump functions that that have
compact support that they're so
so-called c infinity that means they're
smooth okay they're still smooth you
know they're very nice but they have
compact support and so these are sort of
technical tools that um that are used
but but they're not analytic
and so it it means that we're
we're kind of going beyond that that
that pleasant polynomial um
aspect that that was so attractive to
newton and and to euler and to lagrange
so that's that's that's a kind of a a
difference between the real analysis and
the complex analysis i think that we can
we can appreciate that the complex
analysis sort of has this more natural
analytic aspect
which is very like in my algebraic
calculus course which i'm trying to redo
calculus
this polynomial uh orientation is is is
is a key kind of thing we really want to
understand the polynomial story as a
stepping stone to the to the analytic
story
and and that's really where the main
interest lies
for the people watching again the link
to the algebraic calculus course will be
in the description and norman
sorry to call you normally i mean
professor
please let me know
norman has
an ability to make these abstruse topics
extremely
simple it's not an easy task so i
believe i was looking at your algebraic
topology course was it do you have a
course in algebraic to one where one of
the first lessons were on cycles and so
on and i was just thinking man that
that's abs remarkably simple and maybe
you don't i don't know if you see that
but i'm sure you get the feedback that
this is made clear it's lucid
oh well thank you kurt um yeah well i i
think perhaps i can ascribe that to my
relative simple-minded
nature and my
propensity to forget things
so in order for something to stick in my
mind i have to figure out uh kind of a
simple way of thinking about it
you know it's well there's benefits in
not being too smart actually i think you
know that you have to kind of organize
things uh so that you so that you know
where things are you can't remember
where things are so you organize them so
that they're in the right place and
somehow i think of of mathematics a
little bit like that our job is to
organize stuff in in in natural ways so
that so that things are easy to find and
so that everything is sort of natural so
you can sort of see what the next step
is before you actually get there
i'm not a big fan of brilliance actually
you know i don't think math should be
one sequence of brilliant things after
the other i think that's a
misrepresentation i think what we really
want to aspire to is something that's
that's so simple and everything's laid
out and it's completely obvious and you
know i know exactly what he's going to
say now you know
that kind of thing
that's what we can aspire to but of
course it's not so easy but well you're
gifted in that respect
i don't know of many
see
what else this may seem like a
a minor point to you but it's a major
point to those who are watching lectures
online is that your videos have great
audio and great video and there are some
lectures that i would love to watch by
people like witton and their let's say
the titans of a certain field and you
can't watch it because the audio in the
video it's like from the 60s even was
filmed 10 years ago
yeah i commend you on the attention you
put it shows that you actually care
about the people who are watching your
students or your prospective students
the virtual students
you've invested some time and some
energy into how do i make this a
pleasant learning experience
i think it's interesting going beyond
that i mean i think these days more and
more there's um channels which are which
are much you know better at that kind of
thing than i than mine where where
people utilize graphics in in really uh
remarkable ways those humanity and
illustrate things uh you know and i
think that's such a powerful um
tool in fact if i had unlimited amounts
of time i would probably do that too but
i just don't have time to do that so you
know i have to kind of have a bare bones
approach but
i do think you know educational
institutions should be watching what's
going on here on youtube very carefully
because
you know
a lot of learning is is now
potentially possible on youtube it's
like a golden age that we're living in
you know people can watch your channel
it can be exposed to all kinds of
remarkable ideas and thoughts and you
know and we can spend our time in
ultimately really productive ways
and increasingly especially with um
with good graphics and and other things
you know i think the potential for
learning is it's just going to keep on
increasing
it's really remarkable time that we live
in
man yeah i agree okay now speaking about
analysis i would like to get back to
that quickly there's a field called
non-standard analysis do you have gripes
with that field and if so what are
they look i i have um a lot of sympathy
for that field but i also have have some
reservations also
um so non-standard analysis i we can
trace that back to to to leibniz and
newton you know with differentials and
infinitesimals
and in some sense people have been
trying to
to uh get past the 17th century
objections that people had to the
calculus for for a long time and and
that's that's one way of doing it and i
think that's actually quite an important
uh thing to do because physicists and
engineers love to use
differential kind of analysis
you know we have you know this is sigma
and we we change it by d sigma so now we
have sigma plus d sigma you know and
then you treat d sigma as a small but
but non-zero infinitesimal object
effectively
so i have my own uh take on this i i've
talked a little bit about this i think
in one in my famous math problems uh
series uh constructing infinitesimals or
something there's algebraic ways of
doing that and it's basically using
matrix theory so
um
we're talking about extending number
fields extending at the number system so
we have square roots of things well
similarly you can extend the number
systems so that you can create infinite
decimals and and from my view this is
the right way thinking about
infinitesimals there there are objects
that you create out of matrices
typically nil potent matrices that have
the property that their square is one or
their cube is one or some such thing
and
you know what if you do this in the
right way then it becomes
very understandable and and cut and dry
there's nothing mysterious about it
anymore
you know so so i have a lot of sympathy
with with the non-standard analysis
approach however the actual non-standard
analysis approach which is based on set
theory and uh and ultra filters and so
on and so forth uh those
those concepts are are
beyond what i would consider as as
something i'm comfortable with
you're not a fan of set theory now i
understand the axiom of choice but
you're not a fan of zf
no i'm not a fan of cf at all
okay i'll line to the audience wyatt
please
well you know like my view is that is
that
i know there's a 20th century view that
mathematics is based on axioms
so this is something i talk about a lot
but
i don't think mathematics should be
based on axioms what is an axiom an
axiom is an assumption okay you're
making some basic assumption about what
you're studying and i in my view that's
not necessary you don't need to make any
assumptions in fact you shouldn't make
any assumptions
just the way a scientist should not you
know go out in the field and have a
ready-made
okay bunch of assumptions you know one
should be assumption free and one should
one should observe carefully and one
should be very clear about definitions
okay that's really important but i don't
think there's any need to make
assumptions that that's just
representing some kind of fundamental
confusion
now admittedly
you have to start somewhere so you know
there has to be some initial discussion
as to how to to set things up initially
and i think
the sensible thing these days is to
start with the arithmetic of natural
numbers and that's i think more or less
the consensus you know that's a
reasonable place to start
um but we don't need we don't need set
theory for that set theory is a very
attractive branch of combinatorics as
far as i'm concerned you know there's
there's combinatorics and there's sort
of data structures and in data
structures there's there's set theory
there's multi-set theory there's list
theory uh there's there's ordered set
theory so there's there's these
different you know just another
kind of data collection that we that
we can manipulate and utilize for our
constructions
but this idea that it's somehow the
foundation of mathematics that we should
be you know framing everything in terms
of that
that's just not the way it happens
if you look at modern papers you'll see
that they don't actually they don't
actually reference zf you know
almost nobody does that um
it's more uh
a kind of you know when philosophers
press us we say okay look we believe in
zf now leave us leave us alone there's
one example in physics that i know of
where the axiom of choice is used there
might be multiple but i think it's to
say that a module has a basis and i
forget exactly what yeah the axiom of
choice
plays a very special role the axiom of
choice is basically uh an embodiment of
that very principle that i said that we
should avoid
namely this this conceit that we're able
to do an infinite number of things you
know you're not able to do an infinite
number of things so there's no point in
pretending but the axiom of choice you
know puts the finger on and says let us
all officially pretend that we can do an
infinite number of independent things
everybody agreed
okay we're all agreed okay now that so
yeah sure that allows you to do to to do
all kinds of things but do in quotes
you're not actually doing them you're
talking about things
you know because you still can't do an
infinite number of things you can talk
about it and that's all
so anything that's based on the axiom of
choice is in my view
uh highly suspect
and unfortunately that there's quite a
lot of that um floating around we can
have another podcast just about what it
means to do i think that's a fun
just discursively speculatively before
we get to the audience questions what do
you make of penrose's argument against
the computational nature of reality he's
a huge fan of the real numbers and
continuity and i believe see i emailed
ed whitton prior to this and i said what
do you think of ultra finitism and
norman weilberger's views and i sent him
a video and he basically said he doesn't
concern himself with this
okay so people like penrose concern
himself and decide in favor of real
numbers people like ed whitton
say i'm not even concerned about it so
why do you think it is that some of the
greatest physicists in particular these
are only physicists that i'm outlining
they'll add borders on the mathematician
side why do you think they
don't pay attention to the issues that
you're raising i think for a very good
reason and i don't blame them one one
one iota because
when when we're considering uh like that
go back to an infinite decimal right to
a physicist every single
decimal digit is one tenth the size of
the previous one we're going in scale so
as you march down the sequence of
decimals those those entries are
becoming less and less important to the
actual
role that that number is playing in
whatever you're looking at
you know it's the first digits which are
most important and then then their their
importance decreases as we go on
and so by by the time we were down to
the 30th decimal digits
we have we are no longer interested in
in in what that that 31st digit is it
just doesn't interest us and and any
questions about whether these decimal
digits go on to infinity or or not is is
to a physicist completely irrelevant
because it's not going to affect them in
any fashion whatsoever
you know so the physicist is quite happy
to play along and we'll use e and pi and
so on but they'll just immediately
truncate them and then use some finite
decimal approximation to to solve
whatever problem they're working on so
it's it's still a physicist a
philosophical point
so i i i completely uh see why edwin
doesn't concern himself with such things
yeah and that was
what you're outlining is is my view in
that even theoretical physicists are
practical in a sense where
they don't care too much about whether
or not
e is real they care about whether or not
it allows them to predict something now
i know theoretical views you can
excoriate physicists for saying well
your string theory doesn't predict
anything
forget about that so i was viewing the
reals and continuity etc as almost like
i mentioned like an architecture an
architect designs a building it's a
design tool and then
we know that later we're going to
approximate it it allows us to simply
calculate
so you're saying your problems aren't
with them your problems are mainly with
the pure mathematicians who believe oh
absolutely absolutely i i i think
applied mathematically physicists
you just carry on you're doing great um
you know
i think applied mathematics is going
from strength to strength it's pure
mathematics
um that has the serious problems i see i
see
yeah absolutely
how about we get to a couple audience
questions and then that's it
sure
let's see so this question comes from
zero six nine eight five five nine three
on reddit
how would
norman wildberger rephrase the
intermediate value theorem without the
use of free of real numbers
um yeah that's that's a good question
that's a good question um so that
i i would say that's
close to um maybe a more fundamental
question which is how i would uh replace
the fundamental theorem of
algebra um with without real numbers the
fundamental theorem of algebra um you
know asserts that you can
um
factor
polynomials and and and and you can find
zeros okay um so
i i would say that what what we want to
do is is to restate that in terms of not
finding exact zeros but finding
approximate zeros so we have to have a
sense of what it means to be an
approximate zero so for example you know
we could we could say what does it mean
for for a function to have an
approximate zero in a certain interval
it's the same kind of thing that a
physicist would do i mean if you have
some something that you can't calculate
but you know what you're looking for for
some some zero you can't calculate it
exactly but what you want is some some
interval and say well it's going to
cross somewhere in between here and here
but then
yes but that interval is it's it's um
its extent is not clearly defined you
could you could you could look for a
smaller resolution smaller resolution
and so on and get you know better and
better approximations so we have to have
some sort of numerical analysis involved
so we have to have a restatement purely
in terms of rational numbers but it has
to involve intervals and it has and
there has to be an accompanying
numerical analysis
and it it's a it's a major major uh to
do in pure mathematics to to
to replace the fundamental theorem of
algebra and and the intermediate value
theorem is along the same lines um with
with something that's that's accurate
which is purely stated in terms of
rational numbers and which is um you
know
which avoids all mention of infinite
processes
norman why is it that
if
mathematics as it is right now the
mainstream mathematics with the real
numbers and continuity etc why is it
that if it's so flawed
why hasn't it produced major
inconsistencies do you imagine that it's
going to topple at some point that is
contradictory somewhere
no so the the kinds of problems that it
has are problems of
ambiguity
you know that
it's not as if we've actually assumed
something that's that that will
necessarily lead to a contradiction uh
we
we've assumed things that
that obscure the the fundamental nature
of of our reality okay and so the
consequence of that is is is
confusion at various levels and and
missing out on uh a better and more
accurate and more powerful way of
thinking
that's that's really the price that that
we pay
because if we're really willing to face
the music as it is and not the way we
want things to be okay so yes we we may
have to think harder and we may have to
think more carefully and we may have to
be more precise and we may have to go
back down to more elementary things that
we thought we had figured out back in in
in undergraduate level
but as a consequence of that we can
discover so many new interesting things
and perhaps we can help the physicists
you know
i think the physicists
could probably use some some
some new ideas perhaps coming from from
mathematics
and so that the possibility of of
finding such new ideas and finding
exciting new avenues is i think
increased by by by being open to to
looking carefully at the foundational
issues and actually you know addressing
the the weaknesses and not pretending
that they're not there
okay and again for the people who are
watching there will be a part two with
norman on his new ideas of unifying math
and new ideas in physics so if you have
questions for the professor the great
professor then please leave them in the
comments and when we are lucky enough to
have norman on again he'll
hopefully answer some of those questions
okay now in your answer norman you use
the word fundamental reality and is that
we're confused about or not we as me and
you but we as in the general public or
general mathematicians etc that we are
confused about what fundamental reality
is but then earlier we were talking you
mentioned well i don't care too much
about existence this is not an existence
claim but then fundamental reality and
the word is to me sounds like existence
claims which then to me it's interesting
because sometimes i hear this from
people
death of the universe
and so therefore we should base our
entire mathematical system on something
different
and then that's interesting to me
because and i'm just saying this here
for the first time so please allow me to
fumble around reductionistically this is
how we ordinarily think of the universe
is okay if i'm to act it's because of my
psychology which is because of my
neurobiology because of my biology
because of the chemistry which is
because of the physics which is because
of the math not cuz of but uses the math
then if we're saying well our
mathematics needs to be practical so
let's look at the world and then
determine what our mathematics should be
then it's almost like we're basing our
mathematics in physics but the physics
is based in mathematics is that circular
in some way
yeah i'm not entirely sure how to
respond to that um
when someone is saying we should change
our framework for the mathematics in
order to properly reflect the physics
but then the physics is already based in
mathematics
so then there's an interrelated
definition
and i don't know how to make sense of
that so i'm just throwing that concept
out there yeah
i would say i'm not sure if if math
physics is based on math i i would
the way i would think of it is is that
physics is based on on observations so
you have these observations and this
data coming from from the instruments
and your senses and so on and then you
have to model it somehow so then you you
go to the mathematicians and you open
the math books and you see some some you
know which math theories might might
model this particular situation best
okay okay this this this particular
theory looks like it'll work
pretty pretty well but not really well
but
not bad you know okay so you adopt that
and then maybe it gets ingrained in in
successive generations but that's not to
say that somebody can come can't come
along and
you know
replace the mass with some some better
theory and then the physicists can can
readjust
their their thinking
but
i'm thinking that ultimately it's it's
the the world itself that that you have
to respect
you know your obligation is is to is to
is to
yeah um
be
be honest about the world it's not to to
to make us happy or to follow along in
in the way we've been doing things
you can use our tools when they're when
they're appropriate and and and modify
them when they're not perhaps
so i i think generally speaking having a
range of um a range of ways of thinking
it has got to has got to be a good thing
for science for physicists
so i would like i would like there to be
more
wider discussion about foundational
issues in mathematics
i think the computer scientists ought to
have a lot more say in in in in the the
foundational issues like people like
stephen wolfram right i think you know
he has a very deep uh feeling for
foundations of mathematics because
mathematica is all about
foundations of mathematics at some level
you know so um i think uh
having having a wide range of
possibilities can only be good for you
and having a little bit of debate uh um
and and you know and trying to find the
right theories you know the fact it
might be that there are just some some
theories which are much righter than
others and and
it's probably a good guess that it's
those theories that that are are most
likely to be uh useful to you
some people like max tegmark they do
believe in the mathematical universe
that what underlies this is mathematics
so are you saying
i'm not so sure max
no yeah so i i i i do think there's a
mathematical universe okay um i i'm i'm
a little bit of a
i will say platinus but
my colleague james franklin has an
aristotelian point of view you know that
that that mathematics actually can be
found here in the world and i i share
that orientation so i i'm happy to
believe that there's some mathematical
aspect to reality that reality has a
physical aspect and it also has a
mathematical aspect
what us mathematicians do is we take
this very human
centered point of view and we try to
study that that mathematical aspect and
try to to express it in our language in
our words in our vocabularies okay but
there there may be very
many possible points of view of doing
that
so
we're maybe studying the the same
mathematics but there's the potential
for a lot of different points of view on
that on that mathematical reality
there's not just one necessarily one
point of view although in for some
application there might be a
most useful or a better point of view
you know so i i'm an advocate of having
um a wider
and sort of more open discussion as to
the nature of the fact especially the
foundations of mathematics and i think
that's going to be beneficial to physics
for sure
okay we'll just ask two quick audience
questions and then we'll wrap it up so
this question comes from sam thompson
question for norman despite the
difficulties with interpreting real
numbers as classes of predeterminate
infinite sequences as highlighted by the
intuitionists do you see problems with
having infinite index sets for example
do you take issue with quantifying over
the natural numbers in referring to the
steps of a non-terminating computation
or using diagonalization arguments
[Music]
um so diagonalization arguments is maybe
something separate um
again i would try to frame that
in terms of are we assuming at some
point that we're able to do an infinite
number of things
like i i may have um you know some some
set of objects that i'm interested in uh
you know maybe some graphs and then
maybe i lay i can see that there there
could be indexed by a natural number n
so i i have some graph g and i call this
graph g sub n so here's g sub one here's
g sub 2 g sub 3 et cetera
so
but is it the case that that i'm using
an infinite
um
set as an index no that that's that's
that's a big jump okay i'm using natural
numbers i'm saying that if you give me a
natural number you write down a natural
number
please do okay you write down a natural
number okay now i can find uh one of my
graphs over here that corresponds to
that natural number here's the graph
that corresponds to your natural number
i don't have to make any claims as to
whether the natural numbers go on to
infinity or not in order to make that
statement
so this is a very common confusion that
that that people make is that they think
because i want to talk about arbitrary
integers that i want to talk about every
integer as if they're all in some big
basket somewhere you know and then i
just pick i'm just picking one out of
this basket
rather what it is is that there's a road
and i can walk down this road and i can
you know and i can pick up an integer
that's there and then i can walk back
and if i want a bigger integer whether i
have to go down the road again i have to
go further and i grab this bigger one
and and come back with it
um but that's all there is there's
always this road there's no there's no
end of the road there's no you know uh
big ballpark in which which everything
here is happening
this reminds me of someone i forget his
first name lucas is his last name and he
was the precursor to penrose's girdle
argument saying that because of girdles
in completeness theorem it means the
mind is not like a machine as far as we
understand what a machine is and he used
the phrase that a machine can emulate
any aspect of a human but it cannot
emulate every aspect of a human
and so when you said well we can use any
natural number but we can't use every
natural number it reminded me of that
yeah to the child who is listening to
this they may say well
norman if you're saying infinity doesn't
exist then you're saying that only
finite exists so that implies that
there's a maximum number
what is that maximum number why can't i
plus one yeah i know people people say
that a lot and they they want to turn
the argument into a finance argument so
first of all i'm not a finitist i
wouldn't say that i'm i'm a finitist i i
do not believe uh that there is
necessarily a biggest natural number
um
what what i
i'm more likely to think is that as as
you carry on
into the realm of bigger and bigger
natural numbers it was you will slow
down and it will eventually overwhelm
you and at what point you have to stop
by the side of the road and come back it
is dependent on your
your patience and your machine cetera
but you're not gonna you're not you're
not in a position to reach the end so
i'm not i'm not a finitist but i'm i'm
i'm it's more like a classical greek
thinker i i recognize that there's this
this road ahead and has an unbounded
aspect and i'm agnostic as to you know
what what's down that road beyond my
view
so maybe i should say like i have in my
math foundation series i have a string
of videos on on big numbers where like i
look at seriously big numbers like
something like uh
canoes arrow notations such like this
and
so you can generate these these
incredibly uh you know big expressions
that are just mind-bogglingly um you
know big but
um
the existence or or the validity of such
numbers is highly in question because
you can't reach those numbers by an
inductive step-by-step process you have
to reach them by towers of towers of
towers of exponentials etc so you're
leap frogging the the the fundamental
inductive process which sort of
underlies most most arguments implicitly
so it you know it's a it's a question
even whether you know 10 to the 10 to
the 10 to the 10 to the 10 to the 10
whether that's actually a valid number
or not you know that's a and a computer
scientist would fully understand that
because most computer programs are not
going to be able to deal with that thing
just like my program was not able to
deal with with it
you know
so
now the last question this one comes
from divergent koshi that's the username
it's great username i'll give you yeah
you can choose between so
what he so firstly
some apparently some cranks quote
unquote people use your videos to prove
math is bs it's like what are your views
on that you can choose to answer that or
would you call yourself an idealist or a
platonist
um
so uh so the first question yeah look if
you put a lot of stuff up on youtube and
you have uh sort of non-standard
orientation you have to be prepared for
people saying all kinds of things about
you
and i think
that's okay and i'm i'm i'm willing to
wear that um you know it doesn't bother
me overly um
so you know
um
as to the the uh second question
idealist or plaintiff i maybe i'm i'm
not sure if i'm
happy to be in any any either of those
categories i i i think categories are
often maybe as
not as helpful as people might imagine
and
it's best to um
just
try to be honest and uh and
and clear and
and careful you know
but those aren't categories those are
sort of
attributes that one strives for
professor thank you so much
for
being so generous with your time
it went by quickly i don't even know how
much time went by but it was much more
than an hour
yeah well kurt thanks for all those
great questions it's been uh
really fun chatting with you and i look
forward to doing it again
thank you
yeah really i really enjoyed it uh yeah
the time has gone flown by um
usually after an hour i would sort of
fade but i i feel as if yeah it's been
so much the same with me
usually like i know it sounds like no
because i do
four or five hours but
after an hour i can feel when the hour
has passed but i didn't feel do you have
any notes for me anything you'd like me
to take out or no no just just use your
own judgment um i'm sure whatever you
put together will be will be great
okay and thanks again for for doing all
of this stuff you're you're you're
really a champion
and i hope that you're you know you'll
continue to to expand your
your base and uh
you know
really make it happen
it's really good
thank you
yeah yeah and about that last question
about the cranks i've gotten the reason
why i ask you this because
because i interview people on a fairly
wide spectrum
if someone's a materialist you know what
a materialist is so there's materialism
versus idealism if i interview a
materialist the idealists in the comment
section will say why are you wasting
your time with these people and then the
materialists will say to the idealist
yeah i i can't believe you entertained
such a woo and it's so difficult to not
respond to negative comments it's so
difficult norman for me
yeah i have to takes everything from me
but this person said i that i platform
cult leaders and right-wing nuts because
i had on
chris lange who apparently has
right-wing views and i'm just oh man
jeez jeez louise
i don't know one of the things i've
learned
is that you have to sort of develop a
thick skin in in this in this sort of
environment you know like you're putting
your thoughts and your efforts out there
on youtube and and people can respond
you know
anonymously and and
you know they can get away with saying
all kinds of things and and everybody
has not everybody a lot of people have
their agendas that they're they're
trying to push you know and they see
comments as a way of trying to try to
move things in one direction or another
you know so okay
but i guess we just have to wear that as
as as part of the
part of the environment uh yeah it was
taking me i've been you know
putting out youtube videos for 15 years
so i've had plenty of
opportunity of
batting away uh you know negative
comments and so on and eventually you
get used to the use of them you know it
probably initially it bothered me too
but yeah after a while you just get you
get more just ignore it now
yeah you just ignore them yeah
so generally i i because i get lots of
comments i i try to answer the questions
that are sort of worth
you know the answer the good questions
or the good or you know
the good
i think the vast majority of people can
can appreciate you know what what what
we're doing and
we may not agree with with everything
with just fine you know we don't need to
have unanimity of thought as much as we
do i think
um and by the way at some point i i'd
love to to to talk with you about about
all this ufo stuff which which interests
me
not not in in in a public fashion but
just
you know um
because i i'm not i don't have any
opinions worth
saying about them
but i it it really i i think it's such
an interesting um topic and um
and such an important topic i mean it's
it seems to me remarkable that it's not
on everybody's tongue you know
why why why aren't we all talking about
this you know why aren't we it's like
incredible but
for whatever reason when i started
interviewing ufo people i initially was
doing it because
i'm interested is is there something to
this whether
obvious these crap if they are physical
seem to break the laws of physics the
conservative momentum if they have any
mass conservation of momentum and if
they're indeed physical
or just or you know or just or just
false reports
but i i do think it's it's it's really
uh interesting and
um but probably you you've heard so many
points of view that you've probably um
you're probably in possession now of
quite a lot of facts
you know about it you're probably a
minor expert
well
you mentioned that
that you like to simplify and the way
that my brain works is that i
i i have such a confused ontology of
what exists so like we mentioned max tag
my beliefs math like i don't know what
the heck is what exists i don't know
what it means to exist and often many
facts even mathematical facts i'll
understand them but i'll quickly lose
them and i feel like it's because i'm
floating around in a in a void
i've never had this problem until about
a year and a half ago when i started to
do this channel it's actually extremely
taxing for me to learn someone's theory
sorry that's false it's it's ordinary
for me to learn someone's theory it's
taxing for me to remember it it's
because i don't have i don't have a
place to slot new information in it's
all floating and slowly i get glimpses
so when you ask well what's going on
with your folsom i have i have no clue i
can we can talk about some of the
theories out there some of them are wild
some of them make sense with other
accounts
but hopefully i'll be able to say
something useful i don't think so but
we'll see okay professor i i should get
that was so much fun yeah so let's do it
again sometime but you know whenever for
sure
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you